en fin de soirée lorsque nous avons
appris que son véhicule avait été vu
dans la rue de la pension de famille des
charmilles ont fait cette porte à porte
chez tous les chez tous les commerçants
pour présenter la photographie de ce
personnage et ses patrons de l'hôtel de
charme et qui nous indique effectivement
ben brik henry avait loué chez lui si
nous ne prenons d'ailleurs une chambre
depuis le 23 janvier
et nous sommes montés dans cette chambre
a entendu du bruit
patrick henry était là il essayait de
fuir par le dans la terrasse parler de
toi mais les fonctionnaires qui détaille
le commissaire car il est la pj de reims
l'ont arrêté et l'ont emmené dans la
chambre où vous auront découvert oublie
le cadre du bon philippe darphin est ce
que tout cela permet d'assurer qu'il
était seul cela ne permet pas d'assurer
qu'il était seul seule l'instruction l
enquête complémentaire
nous continuons à faire dès ce soir sans
nous arrêter essaiera de les terminer
je peux vous dire moi personnellement
que je pense qu'ils n'étaient pas
accompagnés
lorsque vous êtes entré dans la chambre
avec la police est ce que vous avez
remarqué quelque chose non
j'ai simplement vu les emballages de sac
le sac de couchage qu'il avait acheté
vous envelopper l'enfant et moi je suis
ressorti aussitôt d'achat j'ai ouvert
parce que comme il s'était fermé
d'intérieur j'ai ouvert pour que les
policiers puissent rentrer avec le
individus en question est ce que ce que
vous connaissez de la chambre de ce que
vous avez vu permet de savoir quand et
où l'enfant blanc mais ça c'est un avis
tout à fait personnel que je vous donne
mais à mon avis
l'enfant n'a pas été accueillie ce
qu'est ce qui vous fait penser c'est
juste au dessus du bar ont entendu du
bruit en a entendu marché ici on peut
accéder à ces chambres paris ce sans
passer par le bas et c'est au premier
étage dans cette chambre que s'est
déroulé la soutenable pendant 19 jours
l'enfant mort sans doute depuis le début
de la fère et patrick henry qui va et
vient dans la ville d'abord témoin et
puis suspect et puis de nouveau libre et
ce soir les soupçons l'arrestation l
écroulement atroce de tous les espoirs
patrick henry a donc loué une chambre
ici une semaine avant le rapt et puis un
jour il est revenu il a suivi ce chemin
avec l'enfant quel jour on ne sait pas
encore les preuves de la culpabilité
sont accablantes
mais pour les circonstances on verra ce
qui est sûr tout a été préparé réfléchi
patrick henry à l'insu du logeur avaient
même changé le verrou de la chambre
comment at il pu qui est patrick henry
quand il est venu vous loué cette
chambre vous l'avez vu vous avez parlé
avec lui oui comment utile qui est cet
homme ben c'est un monsieur qui
m'apparaît tout à fait correct c'est un
monsieur taille moyenne
blanc je veux dire au point de vue du
caractère apparent du comportement est
ce qu'il a l'air daf pas du tout pas du
tout pensé que même après le geste qu'il
a commis cette atrocité vous pensez
qu'il est fou ou non d'après ce que vous
avez vu de lui le geste par l'union dont
pour elle qualifié de folie mais le
monsieur n'est pas fou du tout à mon
avis il vous a paru équilibré tout à
fait tout à fait tout à fait